why are the trig ratios called what
they're called okay I will just do the
basic ones
okay well kind of I'll do something
close ten and mmm we'll do second okay
so um we had a look at we had a look at
these with regard to right angle
triangles okay and sure enough that's
where they kind of definition is they
start as ratios right but these are more
than just ratios I said to you okay sign
which that's actually an abbreviation
then it's absolutely sign sign comes
from a word that means curved or curved
right where does it come from
well if and this should be a little bit
familiar to you
if you take the values of sine X and
compare them to values or X and if you
plotted them on a graph just like we
plot it what does X look like and what
does what does x squared look like it
what does log X etcetera etcetera etc
okay if I take values from say 0 to 360
degrees okay and you plot out all right
what's sine of zero and what's sine of
45 and sine of 90 and on and on and on
right the shape you get if I bought all
of these different angles right you get
this curvy shape right we call this a
sinusoidal curve okay so sine it's name
comes from this shape which comes from
if you were to put in if you were to
test out although the values for all of
these different angles that these are
the signs of those angles okay so it's
curvy cosine I really really hope that
at least some of you as I know for a
fact that some of you know what the
curve in cosine stands for because it
also is the variation what's the
question able stands for compliment very
good so this just means the compliment
of sine
hopefully as if pop flipper as in adds
up to my degrees rather than compliment
as in hey nice haircut okay so what does
this mean what's his name if you take an
angle like 30 degrees we know what sine
theta is equal to we were just talking
about it right well whatever it's equal
to it will be equal to the cause of the
complement of that angle right and you
can go ahead you could redraw the
triangles to test it right in the same
way if you take any angle you like
then it's cursor right the cosine of the
complement of that egg will be the same
so that's where it comes from if I think
was really that useful well by the way
you can see why when you draw the
triangles right if you make a phenom
down here and you don't know what
theater is it could be 30 or 40 for
whatever you lie it clearly this
opposite angle over here is going to be
90 minus theta so right from there you
get your definition okay if I call this
let's see well our traditional names for
sides in a right angle triangle right if
I take sine theta that's opposite on
hypotenuse which is B on C right if I
take cause of the opposite angle cos of
90 minus t-not right that's gonna be
adjacent on hypotenuse so that's why
they're the same okay so this side
there's cosine
where does tan come from or more
specifically where does tangent